نبقى الان مع هذه الصور التي تظهر وجود
جثه شهيد ملقى على الارض بعد استهدافه من
قناص اسرائيلي قرب عياده الاونر بمنطقه
الصفطاوي وتطلق قوات الاحتلال النيران على
كلكل من يحاول الدخول او الخروج من
العياده التي تؤوي الاف
النازحين يعني هنا هذا الشهيد ملقى على
الارض كما تشاهدون من زاويه اخرى القناص
يستهدف كل من يحاول الاقتراب منه لانتشاله
هنا اخر صاحب هذه الدراجه لكن لا نعلم اين
زحف في اي منطقه للاختباء من من القناصه
هذا هو الشهيد وهذا هو الشارع الذي يؤدي
الى عياده الوكاله في
الصفطاوي كل من يحاول الخروج او الاقتراب
من هذه المنطقه يتم استهدافه
مباشره
يعني هنا الشهيد ملقى على الارض كما
تشاهدون بعد استهدافه من قناص في منطقه
الصفطاوي الشهيد ملقى على الارض وهناك عدد
من الشهداء كل من يحاول ان يقترب لانتشال
جثامينهم يتم قنصه من هذا الشارع مباشره
الشهداء ملقون كما تشاهدون هذا الشهيد
ملقى على الارض وهناك عددا من الاصابات
هناك مصاب ايضا لا نستطيع ان ان نخرج الى
الشارع كون القناص يستهدف اي احد يقترب من
من
هؤلاء